what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
the future of marvel studios really is
truly exciting right now with over 20
projects coming either on film or to
disney plus there's no shortage of
exciting projects coming and since
there's been so much revealed over the
past year and so much rumored to be
coming today i'll go over every project
you can expect to see down the line both
confirmed and rumored and the rumored
ones are very very exciting and of
course the ones that are confirmed are
also really exciting like the fantastic
four and the x-men and of course our
fourth tom holland spider-man movie but
of course there are some new projects
coming like the new avengers the young
avengers and many many more exciting
projects so let's go through what to
expect from marvel studios over the next
few years and if you love marvel be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos now i won't spend much
time on the projects that we pretty much
already know about by now for example
multiverse of madness is obviously the
next movie that we're going to be
getting and pretty much everybody knows
about that we'll join dr strange wong
the scarlet witch america chavez and
presumably a bunch of other people as
they go through the multiverse and this
movie is what i'm most excited for well
it probably ties with thor love and
thunder which is coming not too long
after christian bale's going to be in
the film natalie portman is returning as
jane foster thor the guardians of the
galaxy are going to be in it for a bit
these two films i am most excited for
but we also have a lot more coming like
moon knight coming to disney plus in
march then she hulk and miss marvel then
we have the i am groot disney plus
series that should be coming this year
as well and then there is a werewolf by
night now at first werewolf by night was
just kind of a rumor it was rumored to
be a disney plus halloween special for
2022 but now we've actually seen
werewolf by night in the moon night
trailer if you missed him he's the guy
that moon knight is beating the absolute
crap out of in the trailer
so the werewolf by night disney plus
show is pretty much confirmed now at
this point we then have black panther 2
wakanda forever and a lot of us are
really excited for this one but mostly
very curious because we want to see how
they're going to handle it after the
passing of chadwick boseman then to end
2022 we have the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special and james gunn did say
that this is going to be important to
watch the next year we have the secret
invasion disney plus show the marvels
which is really captain marvel 2. the
very very highly anticipated guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 where they will
introduce adam warlock and who we
believe to be the villain of the film
the high evolutionary this is also
supposed to be the last film of the
guardians franchise so we're kind of
expecting some deaths in this movie then
we have the echo series now this is a
newly announced series this was
announced during the disney plus day of
2021 now they introduced echo to us in
the hawkeye series she was played by
alaqua cox and did a fantastic job now
spoiler alert if you haven't seen the
hawkeye series yet but they introduced
kingpin in the series and by the end
they revealed that it was pretty much
kingpin who was responsible for the
death of her father now in the comics
kingpin actually kills him which doesn't
happen in the series but he was
responsible for ronan going there and
killing him now at the end she ends up
shooting him in the face and a lot of
people think he's dead but this has
happened in the comics before ekko
shoots him in the face he goes blind in
both eyes but eventually recovers
regains his sight and becomes the
villain again and that is what we're
expecting for the echo series kingpin to
be the main villain and daredevil to
show up considering the fact that she is
his love interest in the comics they are
in a relationship together so the echo
series which should be coming in 2023 is
going to be a pretty exciting series we
then have ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania which is going to introduce the
villain king the conqueror we also have
what if season 2 coming that year and
then we have the iron heart series now
as far as the plot of the iron heart
series goes we don't really know too
much about it yet in the comics she's
granted access to stark technology and
iron man armor and we could probably
assume that this is going to be somewhat
the same in the comics fortunately we
will learn more about her story in black
panther 2 wakanda forever where she is
going to be making her debut and this
has been confirmed by marvel studios
president kevin feige then we have a
movie that a lot of people are really
looking forward to captain america 4
with sam wilson as captain america the
falcon and the winter soldier had a lot
of success and not too long after the
show's finale aired malcolm spellman who
was the writer of that series said that
he will be returning to write a script
for captain america 4. so this movie has
been confirmed by somebody over at
marvel although they haven't officially
announced it yet then we have armor wars
starring war machine little is known
about this disney plus project besides
the fact that it is going to be based
off of war machine don sheadle is
returning to play roadie and i'm sure we
can expect some tony stark and possibly
captain america tie-ins here what we do
know is that he's going to be dealing
with tony stark tech that falls into the
wrong hands and that's where the title
comes from armor wars now we get into
some really exciting projects coming up
like blade marvel has already announced
this and mahershala ali is going to be
playing the vampire and also according
to rumor we have a world war hulk movie
coming this isn't confirmed yet and not
much is known but we assume that it is
going to follow the world war hulk
storyline where the illuminati some of
earth's heroes trick hulk into going
into outer space and to another planet
he ends up getting a wife and she gets
pregnant but she dies due to an
explosion of the ship that hulk was sent
there in and hulk is filled with rage
and comes back to earth and defeats
pretty much all of the heroes on earth
then he puts them in a stadium and makes
them all fight each other this is
definitely the type of hulk that fans
have been wanting to see since we saw
professor hulk in avengers end game we
also have another wakanda series coming
when ryan coogler signed on to direct a
disney plus wakanda project he actually
signed on for a multi-year deal so
expect another wakanda project coming at
some point in time now we can't forget
about loki season 2 because that is
coming although we do not have an
official release date for it but they
left us on a major cliffhanger last time
and last year on disney plus day they
announced a agatha harkness disney plush
show agatha house of heartness as the
official title so we could be getting a
agatha harkness origin story here or she
gets out of westview and wanda spells
somehow perhaps something happens in
multiverse of madness and perhaps we'll
see her in the film then of course we
have the fantastic four we do not know
when they are coming although kevin
feige the president of marvel studios
has said that it is in development right
now so hopefully we'll actually get the
movie within the next two to three years
then we have nova a project that i know
a lot of people are going to be really
excited about kevin feige himself teased
the development of a nova project at
marvel studios in early 2021 reports
then came out that the fantastic four
was iron a 2023 production start and
that nova would also follow a similar
schedule so perhaps we'll get a nova
project whether that's a movie or a
disney plus show in 2024
then of course we will probably get a
what if season 3 depending on how well
season 2 goes we'll also be getting
marvel zombies which has officially been
announced and then an akoyi disney plush
show now this isn't 100 confirmed and
not a lot of people know about this but
in 2021 a trade report focusing on
hollywood's top 100 attorneys for 2021
referenced in a koi series being
developed at marvel studios this could
be one of ryan coogler's projects that
he signed on for and not much is really
known but we presume it might go into
okoye's origin then of course we have
deadpool we're not sure if it's going to
be a deadpool 3 or simply retitled
deadpool but ryan reynolds breaks the
fourth wall as deadpool wade wilson so
everything will definitely be addressed
and made fun of not much is known about
this at all but a lot of fans are really
hoping for a deadpool kills the fox
universe and that's how he gets into the
mcu then of course we have spider-man 4
our fourth spider-man movie with tom
holland now based off of the post-credit
for spider-man no way home we assume
that the villain is going to be venom
but that's not all the spider-man we
have coming we have the animated series
spider-man freshman year coming we don't
have an official release date yet but
what we know is that it'll explore peter
parker's time as he becomes peter parker
in the series in a style that celebrates
the early comic book roots and of course
we can't forget about the x-men at 2019
san diego comic-con kevin feige at the
very end said fantastic four and mutants
which he then later clarified means
x-men they have the rights now back to
the x-men and kevin feige has confirmed
they are indeed working on a project now
pretty much nothing is known about this
at all but fans are really excited to
finally see the x-men in the mcu
interacting with other heroes there's
also been rumors about an illuminati
project coming to the mcu believed to be
formed during multiverse of madness and
then go on to get their own project in
the comics the illuminati consists of
the leader of each superhero group mr
fantastic of the fantastic four
professor xavier of the x-men tony stark
iron man of the avengers black bolt of
the inhumans doctor strange of himself
and namor the submariner of atlantis now
obviously some of these characters have
not been introduced yet and some have
died so it'll be curious to see what the
actual team is then of course we have a
new avengers team eventually coming this
has been confirmed by marvel studios we
just don't know when and it does look
like they are setting up a young
avengers team we're unsure if this will
be a disney plus show or an actual
marvel film but as we get more of the
avengers like america chavez and miss
marvel we'll have a better idea of
what's going to happen and to top it all
off there's rumored to be a ghost rider
project coming we're not sure if this
will be disney plus or a film which i'm
hoping is actually a film and fingers
crossed that it is actually in
development somewhat at marvel studios
right now so as you can see we have a
lot to look forward to with marvel in
the upcoming i would say five to six
years not to mention there are projects
out there that we have no clue about
that they're probably going to blindside
us with that are going to be awesome but
out of everything i listed here what are
you most excited for in the upcoming
years let me know your thoughts down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you